all right so this has happened I'm gonna
give you fair spoiler warning spoilers
on the recent episode of The Walking
Dead are coming in three two one it's
obvious I don't regularly do videos on
Game of Thrones or The Walking Dead and
you know what I do it means [ __ ] went
down and so [ __ ] has gone down because
that [ __ ] who looks like
Rumpelstiltskin from this straight to
VHS video the guy who got he's gotten a
lot of people killed at this point in
his life he has almost gotten Glenn
killed he almost purposely killed Glenn
Glenn does not have good rapport with
this guy it just speaks to the quality
of Glenn's character a cleanse like I'm
gonna give you another shot man when why
are you doing that we already know you
are husband number one in the zombie
apocalypse you don't have to actually be
a saint no Glenn wanted to be a saint
you wanted to give this guy another shot
so they're in a dumpster and all these
walkers off I'm trying to paw through
legs grab him and bring him down me they
have very little space you're like how
are they gonna get out of this but I
imagine me well I mean you don't think
they're going to kill and then Johnny
[ __ ] looks at Glenn he's like thank
you
Wow a sweet shop or just Glenn and blood
just goes and sprays on him and Glenn
has that look like holy [ __ ] that wasn't
pretty is everything all right Glenn
take the stiff throw them into the
zombies give him something to munch on
get out of there sure enough Johnnie dip
shits body falls over on to Glenn Glenn
goes overboard and he just hits the mosh
pit of walkers didn't even there like
maybe you can bring the body on top of
usual the zombie some lunch on him and
think you're dead
nope they proceeded to rip Glenn's guts
out Glenn's dead but you feel like Ben
Kenobi on the Millennium Falcon at that
point you're like oh I feel a great
disturbance in the force is if a billion
voices all cried out at once
[ __ ] the walking dead and then silence
very sure that's what happened but
because of time zone it wasn't all at
once it was it was in section which if
I'm being objective about it someone in
the group really did have to die I'm
saying one of the fan favorites that
people have latched on to his people
have died in the group but they weren't
like the ones you look at you're like
they're never gonna kill them off what
I'm saying a fan favorite did have to
bite it so you feel like the group is
mortal like they can be hurt like people
can die and it happened now at great
cost to us I wish it was someone else I
don't know who else but I just didn't
want Glenda the Glenn's like awesome
plan is like normal dude I would have
out with Glenn I would have a beer with
Glenn the worst part about is it really
feels meaningless this [ __ ] who has
gotten a lot of people killed who should
have died a long time ago whoo Glenn has
given more than enough chances to this
blows himself away it's not like Glenn
sacrificed himself to save this guy out
of faith and he'll be a better person
not like Glenn saved a baby it's just
like this guy blew himself away and then
fell on Glenn and Glenn fill in to the
walkers it's just a [ __ ] situation you
really feel like it's meaningless which
I get in a show like this it's like yeah
it's kind of you don't know who's gonna
go it's not always going to be epic dude
and it makes it feel a lot more real the
same if Glenn was gonna go out I'd want
him to save a baby or something and the
shitty part about it is Maggie's
probably not actually going to know it
happened there are no witnesses I mean
Michonne's like oh the fire didn't light
and someone's like well it just means
they didn't like the fire doesn't mean
they didn't get out so really it's gonna
be one of those things where days are
gonna go by and Maggie's not going to
see Glenn she's gonna be like maybe he's
dead so she's gonna hold on to that hope
and really I don't think they're ever
gonna hit confirmation that Glenn's dead
I hate it when I don't get closure in
things it haunts me it bothers me which
again makes it more real and it makes
you feel like you have to deal with a
tube that's just the way the world is
and I hate that [ __ ] I imagine next
season was gonna be a scene where
Maggie's sitting around on maybe I can't
fire something she's gonna see something
of Glenn's and she's I don't know she's
gonna burn it or something right there
it's gonna show that she has actually
accepted that Glenn's dead but I don't
think it's gonna come for quite a while
I've seen some people argue online like
watch it again if you look at it it's
not actually him getting ripped up yeah
you're right I think it's a prop it's
makeup it's special-effects secrets out
they don't actually kill actors in The
Walking Dead if it looks like it's not
actually Glenn's bodies because it's not
Glenn's body it's a prop they have on
the guy to make it look like it's his
body I'm just saying if something
doesn't look like someone's actually
getting ripped up it doesn't mean the
characters not getting ripped up just
means the actors not getting ripped up
but hey in humoring this theory maybe
Glenn is alive maybe he's sat there in
the zombies munch down on body number
one they were like all right we're not
even gonna continue on to body number
two we're full and Glenn's stumbles into
town alive and is why I don't think that
would be a good idea I mean I don't know
about you but the only thing I hate more
than a beloved character dying is a
studio or storyteller so you don't have
the balls to commit to the fact that
they killed a beloved character
I mean Glenn's dead they'll get [ __ ]
for it people hate it our hearts sank
they broke could you at least respect
the balls it takes to kill a beloved
character like Glenn if they have Glenn
stumble into telling he goes it totally
survived a horde of walkers on me who's
actually the other guy's body on me that
they were tearing up I mean you just
looked cheap and that point you just
look at the Walking Dead is a show that
just doesn't have a spine because it'd
be apparent at that point that anyone
else who wasn't a beloved character like
Glenn would not have walked away from
that people will be able to see through
the [ __ ] of that kind of
inconsistency and I think that'll
backfire on earth that's just me
humoring officially I genuinely think
Glenn is dead because I saw him get torn
up I might sound like a hypocrite like
oh Glenn's dead yeah well don't bring
him back I'm just saying bringing him
back would compromise the whole of the
show yeah in any case those are my
thoughts it sucks I hate losing a
favorite character and I just didn't
want to lose Glenn cuz Glenn was us he
didn't come from anything hard he was
like you know you could tell he was
probably dorky and he was nerdy and now
he's in a zombie apocalypse and he's
still alive he's become a badass you
feel like maybe you could become a bad
egg nope now he's dead which means I
would probably die too so that's that
fascinating thing is the seasons not
done yet there's a lot of [ __ ] that can
go wrong that can go bad so do you think
anyone else is going to die
what do you think of Glenn dying that's
a dumb question anyone just like yeah I
don't care means you don't watch The
Walking Dead you're just talking [ __ ]
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you